HAVE you this year
exams and you have doubts about doing law
but you are not sure what to expect
then watch this video
well what you can expect first
is that you really have to read a lot
you must read in the law
uh in the judge's ruling
in uh lyrics
literature so you must love to read
I also regularly get the question whether you have your bundle of laws
must know by heart
you don't have to
you can just use it during your exam
but you have to know how to deal with it
well depending on your level
you should also take into account that you have little
practice parts
will have uh during HBO you will still
have projects and uh internship
but at the uni it is really only
take exams and click in 1 report
and also you will have a lot of tutorial uh so you will then
Get 1 part in class
but at home you will also have to read a lot
and especially at the uni
uh it's just a bit more than on the uh NB or HBO
so you had the expectation
that the judicial study would mainly be
that you are going to plead and practice this
then I have to disappoint you
it is mainly analyzing the law eh cashuses
solve eh reading statements and stuff
and those are also the skill you are going to learn
during the study
well you have any questions about the court study
let me know and don't forget to follow me